we really think the behavior scientists
are who were waiting for in this area
that we need new techniques to in our
thinking we need new approaches that
will pay it which will value the
selection of healthy foods leadership in
this area is coming from the University
of Pennsylvania Tom wad'n and that group
which is expanded now to their
colleagues have gone to Temple
University obviously we're very
interested in the children's programs
and of course in Bob and Boston we have
David Ludwig at the Children's Hospital
in his optimal weight control approach I
think as well recognized we certainly
salute the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation working with the Clinton
Foundation as far as school lunches
concerned and getting new education to
children we want to draw attention to
women who appear taking the lead to stop
gain weight particularly the Hispanic
and non-hispanic white women they of
course are the best teachers for the
children so that this is another avenue
that we want to address the American
Dietetic Association as 60,000 members
who are all are knowledgeable and how to
take advantage of the science of
nutrition to help with these medical
problems
we worked on a black American lifestyle
intervention program that was quite
helpful because we just told them what
was healthy and then let them take
charge of implementing it in their
community so culturally and ethnic and
racial groups have a cultural diet and
we can re-engineer that to get out some
of the calories particularly oils and
fat in this area and slowly implement
locally grown vegetables and produce in
this area so it's remarkable when you're
talking about getting just two to four
hundred calories out of the diet per day
how you can engineer out in these
culturally specific recipes unnecessary
fat and sugar in this area so it is a
simple solution that has to be adopted
locally I would think that now almost
every community has access to nutrition
educators who can go over a food choice
as I've emphasized before of course you
want to build it into the mypyramid
which has its base vegetables and whole
grains followed by fruits and low-fat
dairy and small parses portions of meat
poultry and and fish in the area but
this really all starts with what you
selected what's in your grocery basket
today and then to construct that into
recipes because people eat meals so
that's what you need to have built
correctly and so you get one
a of a healthy meal and then be guided
from that to what the other meals and
the breakfast is going to look like but
we do have to keep it simple we have to
understand that we're just talking about
selecting food that we eat slowly we
take each bite and chew it and tell it a
liquid we get rid of our hunger we get
pride in how happy are that that it is
healthy food and we know it's healthy
food because it doesn't have added fat
sugar in it I think people don't know
what a calorie is I think people don't
know what a healthy food is I think they
don't know how they're set point is
regulated particularly as far as hunger
is concern so that the Surgeon General
Richard kimono emphasized that that we
have to get a health literacy so
oriented here so people understand these
simple realities so that they can eat
less because they know how many cars
they should be eating how many in a
individual meal there is and then they
need to know where does my hunger come
from and how do I get yo rid of it in
this area and then they need to have a
simple mark a simple identity on foods
that says this is a healthy food
so calorie of course is a you know
expression of the energy that's
contained in the food or the energy
that's expended when you stand up for
example as we're sitting down if we
stand up there would be a fifty percent
increase in the calories we were burning
from a little over one carry to one and
a half you know if we stand up it's
another twenty-five percent so that I
think the way for people to know about
calories is to buy a frozen dinner see
how many calories it is and then look at
what's in that package knowing in bed I
want to learn on a package that is 450
calories now most diet or a lean cuisine
type frozen dinners only have 250 cowers
so you need two of those because if you
eat over 20 minutes 450 cowers in this
area you can learn yourself I was hungry
when I started and now the hunger is
gone so that's the best way and then of
course the other one is that I know that
my body burns 15 hours per pound per day
and so if I'm a hundred and fifty pounds
that's 225 powers you know if it's 170
then of course it's a 85 on top of the
170 and and so it's easy to know with 15
cars per pound how many towers I'm
burning then you get on the scale and if
it stays it's saying I say wow you know
I consume 225 cowers I'm 150 pounds in
this area and my weights the same if you
lose weight then you know that you're
consuming less calories than this 15
hours per pound
well I the old adage of talking to talk
versus walking the walk that you know
there's so many things that that we want
but we're not willing to put in the
effort to do them and I think this is a
perfect time to be talking about this
subject because it does appear you know
that we're going to have to use less
gasoline or less oil and less and waste
less fuel for our car and we waste a lot
of food and we eat too much food so this
is a good time to take action and I
think people are ready we already have
these statistics that the 21st century
is associated with stopping weight gain
that's the first step to go from eating
equal to what you need to under 18
verses what we were doing the last 20
years of the 20th century and then we
were overheating
you